[Music]
Raven Simone is reflecting on how it
felt coming out a decade ago back in
2013. speaking with E news recently
Raven admitted there were a lot of
challenges adding there was the
crumbling of the wall that I had put up
for so many years and I felt very
vulnerable it was an interesting wound
that was opened up in public now back in
2020 during an interview with people
Raven spoke about her brief Hiatus from
Showbiz saying it helped her come to
terms with her authentic self saying
what it did was help me with my
sexuality I actually had time to think
for myself and no one to tell me
differently it helped me realize that
I'm kind of addicted to the industry
because of the fact I had been in it for
so long I had to transform that
addiction into something that is
positive for me because I was getting
very toxic to myself and others now of
course Raven currently stars on and is
an executive producer on the super
popular series Raven's home and she
continues to Champion the queer
Community the series includes the
Network's first transgender character on
Disney Channel portrayed by Juliana Joel
and when I caught up with the actress
last year she told me the impact that
her character Nikki has had on viewers
Nikki just because your transgender
doesn't make you different right it
makes you amazing no I'm not different
because I'm trans I'm different because
I'm an heiress
I've had some very very very very
beautiful messages from trans youth
saying how seeing they feel to see an
out trans person and character on Disney
Channel but also family members of trans
people it's chained to a few people's
minds which I love we're human and we're
deserving of of not just playing these
roles on camera
but living these lives behind camera
[Music]